[Musica]
sono nicola fossaceca ho 38 anni faccio
il cuoco
oggi vi parlerò un po della della mia
storia ma in realtà di quello che faccio
di quello che faccio il mio quotidiano
e delle riflessioni che faccio perché il
mio lavoro poi mi porta molto a
riflettere a pensare a pensare
all'ospite come si trova a tavola se sta
bene insomma mi voglio e mi devo porre
tantissime domande ma questo a me piace
perché mio carattere
e così abbastanza
ansioso ma un anziano positiva
un'anziana che ti porta magari a un po
di
crisi proprio quando trovi la soluzione
arriva la grande soddisfazione
una delle riflessioni che facevo proprio
in questi giorni mentre guidavo mentre
lo ha assolto ai miei pensieri era capo
lo viviamo in un mondo di plastica
detta così insomma si pensa proprio
all'oggetto rifiuto a rifiuto il mare
insomma quelle cose che ormai in ci
rendono molto
sensibile all'argomento
in realtà io
vado un pochino oltre per mondo di
plastica
intendo anche un mondo poco funzionale
per certi aspetti o proprio la
componente e oggettistica e gli oggetti
insomma ho notato che questo meno
duraturi rispetto a qualche anno fa
prima c'è la tendenza a produrne sempre
di più a renderli più
fruibili e quindi magari si tende a vi
faccio un esempio sciocco magari me in
cucina quando vado a comprare un oggetto
magari perché lo trovo a volte non mi
nascondo perché magari costa meno so che
i ragazzi maltrattano le cose in cucina
ma è normalissimo che prendo questo uno
spremiagrumi uno spremiagrumi di
plastica insomma a casa alla sua durata
ristorante dura veramente un un tempo
limitatissimo
e ci rimango male ci rimango male non
per soltanto perché l'oggetto si rompe
perché dico cavolo se fosse stato un
qualcosa oppure quando compri un
qualcosa che ti durati dà soddisfazione
titolare nel tempo insulti lascia magari
anche un ricordo perché potrà paese vivo
molto ti ricordi associo molto le azioni
profumi ai ricordi
e quindi mi delude
allora penso poi dopo al mio lavoro a
quello che faccio e quotidiano
voglio proprio essere all'opposto non
voglio deludere
l'ospite voglio andare a fondo
sono innamorato del mio lavoro e quindi
vado a cercare uno a far di far fare
un'esperienza profonda anche il
contrario non deluda ma lasci un segno
un segno positivo ovviamente
come lo faccio lo faccio dedicando tanto
tempo al mio lavoro attraverso la cucina
i piatti e allora l'opposto penso e vi
faccio un esempio di un piatto che
facciamo da qualche settimana che è una
triglia allora faccio un breve
introduzione abbiamo ristorante dove si
fa una cucina creativa
o perlomeno una cucina magari creativa
profonda una cucina che guarda molto la
tradizione e quindi alla sostanza alla
storia a tutto quello che è passato
perché per la cucina
e storie famiglie la nonna il luogo dove
vai in vacanza insomma tantissime cose e
la mettiamo un profilo un po più moderno
una chiave un po più attuale quindi dei
sapori un po più digeribile magari già
questo è un tema insomma importante la
salute però anche da sotto l'aspetto
visivo magari sembra un qualcosa di chi
sa che proprio quando lo mangio magari a
lascia un altro segno l'esempio che
facevo sull'aprilia una triglia alla
brace quindi la sfi le chiamo da
cuciniamo sulla brace aggiungiamo una
salsa di capperi e
del radicchio
e l'idea del recupero appunto del piatto
che serve a dare maggiore sapore
profondità questo piatto è la lisca la
lisca della teglia quindi noi
sviluppiamo la triglia e poi diciamo ma
che ci facciamo con questa o che la
butto questo una volta magari poi man
mano prendendo consapevolezza ea volte
anche la necessità che proviamo usarla
si fanno i fondi con le carni perché no
con i pesci e dall insomma è partito è
partita questa salsa di thriller che poi
va a coprire anna appare a completare il
piatto e dà maggiore profondità
a me torna utile perché comunque insomma
è un lavoro anche di espressione per noi
in cucina utilizzare tutte le parti di
in un ingrediente e all'ospite fa molto
piacere perché insomma c'è una sorta di
insapore nascosto che è dato da quello
dalla lista che c'era attraverso
questa salsa quindi un esempio di
recuperare un
una parte di un ingrediente chiaro a
casa magari insomma se si ha meno tempo
per cucinare noi lo facciamo di mestiere
15 ci viene automatico
proprio stesso tempo dare profondità
all'esperienza significa anche
l'ingrediente la ricerca
dell'ingrediente
sembra sembrava bene scontato per certi
aspetti
però voglio voglio precisarlo anche in
un piatto semplice se le materie prime
riescono a essere materie prime solide
serie danno tanta espressioni e quindi
riescono a raggiungere quell'obiettivo
di cui parlavo prima un altro piccolo
esempio di un piatto è un raviolo di
ricotta in un progetto di crostacei un
piatto che arriva semplice un ravioli in
brodo che magari può lasciare un
attimino pretese di chi sa e suscita un
attimino già la la sensazione della
chiesa come questo piatto parte che
lì anche un lavoro molto semplice di
recupero delle teste dei crostacei per
andare a fare un cassetto un progetto
con il tegame di terracotta quindi la
tradizione nella tradizione del luogo
vasto e circondario e quindi un sapore
un profumo che poi arriva dentro al
piatto poi però c'è un altro ingrediente
abbastanza il principe diciamo nel
piatto che la ricotta e lidi tema la
ricotta e è un po un simbolo della mia
idea di cucina è un prodotto che posso
trovare dappertutto dal dal supermercato
che distribuisce quindi distribuisce in
quantità e non lo guardo come un
qualcosa di negativo anzi insomma non è
che se esistessero solo i piccoli
produttori si farebbe la guerra per
andare a trovare il prodotto quindi ben
venga anche la grande distribuzione un
certo senso che poi diventa sempre più
consapevole ma dare profondità un piatto
lo faccia anche attraverso una ricotta
di un
produttore un pastore in un certo senso
mio amico che ha il suo pascolo in
nel luogo giusto quindi produce questa
ricotta autentica e fa sì che il piatto
sia
più forte che lascia il segno insomma
che sia il contrario un po di quel mondo
di plastica che mi viene in mente che mi
dà un po fastidio
quest'anno due piccoli esempi poi mi
sono portato questo che un salvagente
così magari se vado un attimo in
difficoltà lo riesco a guardare non
chiede un applauso ma ma quasi magari a
cena
quindi la sostenibilità nel mio mondo è
molto importante
o perlomeno si dà tanta importanza al
fuoco alla cucina al master chef i
cuochi non salveranno il mondo però i
cuochi sicuramente sono
sono dei dei soggetti che riescono a
sensibilizzare nel loro piccolo la loro
cucina il loro cliente e come magari in
questo caso magari darmi qualche darvi
qualche
messaggio
la scelta della materia prima è
importante
per quanto mi riguarda cerchiamo di
rimanere il più vicino possibile al mio
luogo per evitare tutto quello che
magari ne
vidi negativo ne consegue immagino
la frutta e la verdura ovviamente
rigorosamente di stagione da noi non
entra più un qualcosa che è stata
all'altro dall'altra parte del mondo e
che non è più di stagione questo insomma
ormai ci siamo sensibilizzati per
fortuna già da un po e immagino anche
voi in un certo senso è lo stesso vale
per i pesci cerchiamo di
approvvigionarci con il mercato locale o
abbastanza locale e tiriamo fuori la
nostra creatività per per utilizzare
magari quel pesce piuttosto che quell
altro pesce che non si è trovato in quel
periodo nel mercato e poi
e poi nulla in cucina
con i ragazzi cerco sempre di di
sensibilizzarli all'argomento
sostenibilità agli sprechi
di diverso genere di diverso tipo
in quel modo riesco a a lavorare anche
più sereno
un'altra parte importante della mia
storia della mia vita
il collegamento che ho con la natura
attraverso
dei momenti che mi creo passo diverse
ore del giorno al lavoro però però la
possibilità vado magari a
fare una passeggiata a raccogliere delle
erbe feci un ostaggio in un grandissimo
ristorante in trentino quattro anni fa e
ho visto che liberamente il
era un ristorante utilizzavano soltanto
i prodotti del loro territorio in 20
giorni non ho visto un limone non ho
visto un pomodoro per caravan fuori
stagione e non era il loro territorio
sono tornato poi dopo nella mia realtà e
ho iniziato ad apprezzare ancora di più
quello che ci che c'è intorno
ea fare queste passeggiate a raccogliere
delle erbe spontanee che insomma sembra
o e magari poetica come cosa ma a me
serve molto per
ricaricarmi per guardarmi attorno per
sentire i profumi i profumi della della
nostra costa piuttosto che se sento su
in montagna e utilizzo questi prodotti
per
per cucinare per caratterizzare la mia
cucina perché poi dopo in un passaggio
quello che può differenziare insomma
un'esperienza anche quella care
caratterizzarla e questa è una cosa che
volevo condividere con voi penso che
comunque siete giovani la bellissima
storia all'inizio della corsa la corsa
finché si inciampa e poi li significa
che magari si inizia a diventare un po
grani io forse sto attraversando quella
fase in casa sono un eterno bambino ma
comunque insomma sono lì e mi sono
fermato un pochino
a vederla così con un po di poesia è un
po più di calma
e quindi l'utilizzo ora
una cosa che poi man detto eto'o mi
raccomando almeno un consiglio su come
come utilizzare un prodotto fare far
ecosistemi da a casa dallo allora mi è
venuto in mente perché in questi giorni
stiamo vogliamo stiamo lavorando sul
carciofo
premessa che a casa immagino che
comunque gli avanzi si creino è normale
nonostante ci può essere la
consapevolezza nel fare la spesa e stare
attente alle scadenze eccetera però
insomma si creano qualche giorno fa un
mio amico mi diceva da abbiamo fatto un
tiramisù a casa e
abbiamo usato solo i tuorli gli albumi
non sappiamo che farci sono state lì in
frigo e detto a quando apprendi li
utilizza ti fai una un letto in bianco
fai una colazione proteica leggera e
questo è un passaggio per recuperarla
alla fine ce ne sono infiniti c'è la
rete dove andiamo spesso cercare cose
anche lì e può essere uno spunto per
riutilizzare i nostri avanzi i nostri
scarti per
sensibilizzarci ancora di più nel nostro
piccolo e invece mi è venuto un altro
esempio uno specifico sulla verdura sul
carciofo carciofo che un fiore già
questo è un bellissimo buonissimo la
nostra zona è caratteristica nel periodo
primaverile adesso sto usando dei
carciofi già
di una parte della puglia vicino a noi
la parte superiore è insomma vedendo i
ragazzi che oppure quando puliamo calcio
c'è tanto scatto queste foglie che poi
generalmente si fanno vanno buttare come
altri scarti di verdura gli utilizzi
sono tanti
ma nello specifico con il carciofo
abbiamo fatto proprio in questi giorni
un semplice decotto un brodo ci piace
bere d'inverno le cose calde in cucina
per tenerci perché è quindi ti ponte
abbiamo provato con il carciofo è buono
poi abbiamo scoperto che insomma dietro
a
queste foglie di carciofo questo decotto
abbiamo fatto una piccola ricerca sono
uscite 10 proprietà benefiche del
carciofo il calcio fantozzi dante
per il genere al fegato
insomma fa benissimo stimola la diuresi
e quindi fa un pochino
dimagrire e previene il diabete ma
tantissime cose e poi un sapore molto
piacevole che poi si può anche
aggiungere un erba una spezia in creare
quindi un consumo e questo era un
piccolo consiglio immagino siate giovani
non so se magari tutti
apprezzate le verdure però insomma è un
qualcosa di poi con le verdure si
possono fare tante cose mi vengono in
mente le verdure perché generalmente si
si puliscono si pulisce l'insalata e le
foglie esterne mia mamma non voglio che
io non voglio informare mia mamma
stiamo poi è brutto
magari per abitudine si scartano ho
conosciuto e qui insomma le emozioni e
tante perché è un personaggio fortissimo
è un ragazzo che come stile di vita per
descriverle in sintesi vive nella natura
insomma contatto è vicinissimo proprio
deciso di vivere alla tua fare il
contadino è una filosofia sua bellissima
infatti ogni tanto valore tanto che non
vado ma vado a trovarlo perché mi dà una
carica vitale pazzesca
e andare a comprare le verdure da lui è
insomma
già in macchina inizia a button fa ma
che fai ha detto al gore foglie un po
più brutte di mantova da queste sono le
foglie più buone sono quelle che stanno
a contatto con il terreno il terreno
ovviamente il terreno suo che non tratta
per niente pro sono quelle più ricche di
sali minerali di vitamine e gli ho detto
vabbè ma magari il sapore un po più duro
è mi fa caspita fi fuoco tu dovresti
dirmi tu a me come e quindi potresti
leggermente scottarle
un pochino sì in tedesco e le mangi
piuttosto che fargli una fermentazione
ora non vi parla delle fermentazioni che
insomma
il rischio di annoiarvi però anche il
libro e ho scoperto un nuovo mondo
semplice anche lì facendo delle ricerche
chiedendo oppure sui social condividendo
la domanda come si fa questo insomma c'è
tutto un mondo che va a cercare il
benessere la
possibilità il recupero la
consapevolezza e tutto quello che c'è di
buono in cucina perché insomma ci sono
tantissime cose buone spero di aver
contribuito anch'io oggi a lasciare un
piccolo messaggio di positività di
consapevolezza e di non fermarsi magari
al base è sempre fatto insomma andare a
cercare sempre qualcosa di diverso in
cucina nel recuperare nel guardare nel
chiedere nell'informarsi alla fine porta
porta progresso fa star bene con noi
stesse ma riesce a rispettare tutto
quello che ci circonda
[Applauso]